we know if we take all of the points in
the x y plane where x squared plus y
squared is equal to one we get ourselves
the unit circle let me draw the unit
circle
that's my y y-axis
this is my x-axis and the unit circle
has a circle with a radius one so that's
x is equal to one that's x is equal to
negative one that's y is equal to one
that's y is equal to negative one and
the unit circle looks something
let me draw it something like this i
think you get the point let me see if i
can fill it fill it in a little bit
better so you realize that it's not a
dotted circle so there that's my best
attempt at drawing at drawing the unit
circle
and we also know that the traditional
trig functions or maybe we should call
them the circular trig functions are
actually defined so that the if you
parameterize so if you were to take
x is equal to cosine
of t
and y is equal to sine of t then you
pick any t right over here and by
definition it's going to sit on the unit
circle by definition x squared plus y
squared is going to be equal to 1. so
you pick any t it's going to sit
someplace on this unit circle or another
way to think about it is as if you start
to vary t you're going to start tracing
out this circle and we know that t
corresponds to the angle with the
positive x-axis so in this case that
right over there is t
now wouldn't it be neat if there were a
similar analogy for not the unit circle
but something that we could call the
unit hyperbola
so let's
so that's our little review of
trigonometry right there traditional
trigonometry now let's think about the
unit hyperbola well x squared plus y
squared equals one is a unit circle well
i'll just say that x squared
x squared minus y squared equals one i'm
just going to call this i'm just going
to call it my unit
my unit hyperbola or unit rectangular
hyperbola hyper
bola and this is just a little bit of
review from conic sections but it would
look something like this
it would look
it would look something like i don't
actually want to make it completely
analog so it would look something
so that's my y-axis
this is my x-axis
and then we can say well if y is 0 x
could be positive or negative 1.
so i guess you could think of it that's
kind of the unit part where does it
intersect the x-axis
so that's positive 1 that's negative 1.
and then it has asymptotes y equals x
and y is equal to negative x and we go
through the intuition on that on the
conic section videos
that's y equals x
y equals x is that dotted line y equals
negative x
is that dotted line right over there
y is equal to negative
x and then this thing is going to look
like this
it's going to has going to have a right
half that does something like this
that does something like this is all a
review of conic sections it gets closer
and closer to its asymptotes so just
like or 2 y equals x and y equals
negative x and the same thing on the
left hand side it's going to do
something
something like
something like that
wouldn't it be neat
wouldn't it be neat if we could
parametrize x and y's in a similar ways
with different functions maybe some like
analogous functions so that we get a
similar type of property and you might
guess what those functions are but let's
actually try to verify it what happens
what were what would happen if x
is equal to
is equal to our hyperbolic cosine of t
which is the same thing as e to the t
let me write a little bit different e
to the t plus e to the negative t
all of that over 2 and y were to be
equal to
hyperbolic sine of t
which is equal to e to the t
minus e to the negative t over 2.
wouldn't it be neat if there were an
analogy here if you over here you picked
any t in our and based on this
parameterization based on our circular
trig functions you ended up with a point
of the unit circle wouldn't it be
amazing if at for any point t over here
you ended up with a point on our what
we're calling our unit hyperbola well in
order for that to be true with this
parameterization x squared minus y
squared would need to be equal to one
let's see if that is the case
so x squared
x squared minus y squared
minus y squared is equal to
well let's square this business it's
equal to e to the 2t
plus 2 times the product of these two
things 2 times e to the t times e to the
negative t well this is these are this
is just e to the 0 right over here which
is 1
plus
plus e to the negative 2t e to the
negative t squared all of that over
all of that over 4 and then from that we
will subtract y squared minus
minus
so the numerator is going to be e to the
2t
minus e minus 2 times e to the t e to
the negative t and then plus e to the
negative 2 t
all of that
all of that over
over 4. so immediate couple of a couple
of simplifications here e to the t
e to the t times e to the negative t
that's just e to the t minus t which is
equal to e to the zero which is equal to
one so this is going to be one that's
going to be 1 and so we're going to have
a 2 in either of those cases and if we
were to simplify it all of this stuff
right over here i'll do it numerator so
this is going to be equal to over our
numerator of 4
e to the 2t
e to the 2t
plus 2
plus e to the negative 2t
and then we have minus e to the 2t minus
e to the 2t i'm just distributing the
negative sign plus two
plus two and then minus e to the
negative two t minus e to the negative
two t well this is convenient
this cancels oh that that's hard to i
was writing it in black black's not an
easy color to see this let me do it in
green this cancels with this
this and this also add up to 0 and
you're left with 2 plus 2 over 4 which
is indeed which is indeed equal to 1. so
this is a pretty good reason to call
these two functions a hyperbolic trig
functions these are the circular trig
functions you give me a t in these
parameterizations we end up on the unit
circle you vary t you trace out the unit
circles here
you for any realty we're going to assume
we're dealing with real numbers here for
any real t right over here we're going
to end up on the unit hyperbola right
over here and in particular we're going
to end up on the right so it's not
exactly over here pretty much any of
these points could be parameterized
right here over here we're going to end
up at a point on the right side of the
unit hyperbola the reason why it's the
right side is you go straight to the
definition of cosh t this thing can only
be positive this thing can only be
positive e to the t can only be positive
e to the negative t can only be positive
so this is
only
only
only positive but you give any t you
will end up on this hyperbola
specifically the right side if you want
points on the left hand side then you
would just have to take the negative
cosh t and the sign the height the
negative cosh t and the cinch t to end
up right over there but it's a pretty
it's a pretty pretty pretty neat analogy
we were looking at euler's identity and
we kind of said oh well let's just start
playing with these things and you know
there seems to be a similarity here if
we were to remove the eyes and all of a
sudden we've discovered another thing
that there is this relationship here was
this relationship between these trig
functions and the unit circle here
between our newly defined hyperbolic
trig functions and the unit hyperbola
and you'd also find if you were to vary
t it's going to trace out just as if you
vary t here traces out the unit circle
you vary t here it will trace out the
right hand side the right hand side of
the unit hyperbola for this
parameterization right here